congratulations on your opening weekend
331 million worldwide
talk about cultural impact
the impact on society what does that
mean for you Ryan I'm going to start
with you and work down but I think about
it in terms of people going to see it
which which means a lot
um because we worked on it real hard for
a long time and
um I was working with people who were
really good at their jobs
really smart
um all very in demand you know so so I
always felt
a lot of gratitude whenever I was able
to be around them Angela what is it like
for you to see on Twitter on Instagram
on Tick Tock little kids going out to
see this movie like parents everybody
like generations of family at the box
office this weekend
uh extremely gratifying satisfying
um like Ryan said we work very very hard
and you you know and then you you
release it you know you release the gift
and you you hope it'll be received and
uh for it to be received in the manner
that it has this weekend
um
and for us to satisfy that longing and I
think it it comes back to the lead the
head and that's Ryan and his vision and
his passion and his heart his tenacity
those kids were ready for their
superhero they were ready for it they
got dressed right away after bp1 it
didn't take them but of a second to
Adorn a panther suit or a door milage
and and uh or Cherie and I I feel it
gave them some hope and it gave them a a
a a thing that they could look up to and
also be uh you know Elevate the it
elevated their sense of self
and so it just meant like I had done
something for them uh beyond what I
wanted to do for us for the culture for
us as a film family for my own
accomplishments as a costume designer I
had really given a gift to the children
and that really meant the most
it is nice to know that these images are
out in the world and that these
characters out in the world and they're
growing and they're they're changing and
they're confronting things that are
complicated and interesting and real
uh and to be a part of that is you know
is all you can hope for because when
you're making a movie it is part of the
craft but the other part of it is the
story and if there's any inspiration or
any sort of
impact you can make on people that we
should be so lucky
the idea of being able to be a part of
something that has a meaningful impact
on people of all ages children adults
um
to speak to the complexity of the
humanity of the people
multi-dimensional characters all of
those
um all those things that stay within the
stay within the fabric of someone's mind
and and how they see the world around
them is is really a special thing and to
to do it with people that you care about
also is just wonderful
it is such a beautiful story about grief
and motherhood
Ryan talk about picking up
your pen or opening your laptop again
after Chadwick had passed and how you
were gonna
you know tell the story and move this
forward I think for all of us
when you're an artist and you work in a
creative medium you blessed to have an
outlet for things that you're feeling
um questions that you might be
processing things that confuse you about
the world about yourself
um and it was a little bit of that
you know I had we all had to recalibrate
man because we love that though you know
like
um he was one of those people to know
him was to love him but to work with him
you know
was to be in love with him you know is
is the truth you know we we would talk
um about what what to do and and
um think about what he would want us to
do and and eventually we we landed on
this this story in this movie and and as
we were going through it I realized oh
this was the only thing we could do you
know what I'm saying like sometimes in
life is like one answer you know
um and I was grateful that we that we
landed on this one but it wasn't um
it wasn't without a lot of thought you
know um and a lot of like reflection on
what Chad was all about you know um
and uh and that was how that was how we
did it and once we once we landed on
this idea we just kind of poured
ourselves into it and things were
revealed you know what was it like
revisiting her this time as a woman
mother who was lost her son and is also
the queen and just exploring this
beautiful storyline it um you know
coming back to this character
um that you explored a bit before that
was that was a luxury you know and then
to have the opportunity to do even more
than you did the first time and that a
lot on your shoulders you you felt that
you you felt I felt and welcomed it
um as a character as Angela as the
actress as Artist as collaborator you
know um I just welcomed that I mean I
had to swim I had to save I had to
I had to sit in a throne that was
inhabited by my son and that that was
that was weird that was wild that was
odd that was
you know
and you just had to approach it with
with Grace and humility and with with a
mother's fierceness
you know
yeah that empowerment is amazing yes
foreign
I'm not going to ask you how many
costumes you actually designed for this
film because this is the definition
I mean thank you for not asking me for
that
I get that question a lot but it's hard
to count
but we had nine new superheroes and
Military factions in this film and four
crowns on Queen Ramona
um and that's a lot I mean Ryan wanted
to elevate this film with the uh the
Dora armors elevated the Jabari get new
armor there we introduced the Navy
uh we have Riri and we have midnight
Angels there was it was jam-packed there
was not a moment to even think
um and queen ramonda taking the throne
and creating
um the leaders classrooms was you know
really wonderful because when Angela
comes into the fitting room she's
prepared and she's in character a bit
because she's going to look at herself
as the queen in the mirror and hold
herself as the queen which is what you
want to see and a fitting and then when
we got together in Atlanta you know pour
ourselves into the art and that was an
honor it was an honor to to be able to
have that opportunity to honor Chadwick
and to do things that we felt were
beautiful and were part of the culture
and to immerse in a new culture the the
Mayas the tolucaniels and uh so it was
it was a lot it's a lot
so when Ryan says Ruth we're gonna go
underwater
someone said I should have hung up
[Applause]
but I didn't
I don't know if any of you paid
attention but the department has so many
females
like what was that like and talk about
yes
like you know why was that important
especially on this film to have so many
like female Department I mean the truth
is we just got the best at every level
you know
um and if that happens to be female
great uh but uh yeah up and down our
crew I think was barn on our best crew
we've ever had on a Marvel film and and
I do think
you know the returning people you know
who are all on the stage it helped to
weather the storms when it got tricky
because
we had been through so much even on the
first movie so you have that Fellowship
you have that family of knowing when
anybody's having a down day you can
always turn to somebody and that's
fantastic but uh um including Hannah
Baker as well who's not here you know
Autumn was new to us but Autumn uh is
incredibly talented and I think really
wanted to do the movie partially because
of the story Ryan was telling and
thematically again she is a mother as
well she was very interested in in that
a theme to explore you know artistically
through the through the lens
um but it you know
it's we just had we had the best crew uh
and and we couldn't have survived a very
difficult shoot without the crew we had
so I couldn't be more thankful to
everybody who you saw in that very long
credit troll every one of those people
was responsible for making the film that
you saw today so
Angela last words from you
the amount of women who feel empowered
after seeing your performance and black
women who feel so empowered like what is
that like like what would you say to
them
um take it home
[Laughter]
yes less feeling powered let's be
empowered yeah we are we are all that
you know of course sometimes you know
there we all have moments where we feel
like we're you know short on the short
side of it but ultimately I mean and
that's this kind of character is
indicative of what the characters that
I'm have been attracted to you know
they're resilient they fall they find
themselves in in circumstances but
you know they find that you know they
find that rock to hold on to and they
pull themselves up you know in a sense
and and they are there you know they
stand strong so um yeah I'm I'm very
glad that people are enriched by
the
essence of of of of of of a woman like
this
because yes she's Queen
and we struggle but we should we are
queens and she is mother and she is
friend and she is counselor thank you
everybody congratulations and thank you
for that incredible insight into your
process in the film thank you everybody
[Applause]